I'm the question of what can accelerate
growth in the Arab world historically
this region has been driven by
government initiatives government
programs and I really think we are
entering a new phase where are all
segments of society need to participate
in the growth it's no longer digitally
the function of the government or the
function of the private sector you need
the government the private sector and
the civil society all engage trying to
figure out on their own in their own
ways how they can spur growth in
different sectors of society so that's
one big area that needs to be addressed
is how to get participation across all
sectors of society the other thing that
will accelerate growth in the Arab world
is innovation I know it's a bit of a
cliche but innovation there is not
enough sufficient amount of innovation
in the Arab old and not we just not on
technologies but in other areas in terms
of the way we do business in terms of
the way we drive change in our societies
and in terms of the way we create new
tools to address some of the challenges
in the Arab world